polymerase chain reaction
or pcr is a simple yet essential way to
make copies of a small amount of dna
by exploiting dna's natural ability to
replicate itself when a cell divides
the first step is to extract a small
amount of dna from a sample
taken from an individual or piece of
evidence
the dna is mixed with a chemical
cocktail including natural enzymes
synthetic chemicals called primers and
four nucleotides
adenine thymine cytosine and guanine
after filling tiny plastic tubes with
the mixture
a technician places them in a
microwave-sized machine
that heats and cools the tubes to a
series of precise temperatures
the changing temperatures ignite a chain
of events
beginning with the denaturing or
unzipping of the double-stranded
molecules
next the primers bind to the individual
strands at precise locations
a process known as annealing ushered in
place by the primers
enzymes steer the
you